the mighty lion around 90 of them live
in Uganda's Queen Elizabeth National
Park even though it's home to a wide
range of species there isn't sufficient
prey for the large carnivores so
sometimes the lions venture into
neighboring villages where they prey on
the cattle the Lions came at night they
frightened the cows out of their
enclosure when the cows ran out the two
lions chased them and grabbed one of the
lucra they tackled the cow and devoured
it it was a big healthy cow that had
recently given birth they just devoured
it well to safeguard their cattle
herdsmen have been accused of poisoning
the big cats with pesticides dr. Ludwig
Seifert a German conservationist who
came here in the 1970s wants to keep the
conflict with the Lions from escalating
he works for an organization called the
Uganda carnivore program aware of the
dangers posed by the predatory cats he
sends out Scouts to inform him whenever
there's a lion attack
we got a distress call via our scout
that there is another livestock kill so
we came immediately she showed us the
carcass approximately a quarter was
eaten and we also look at the way it is
eaten you know a leopards feet in a
different way as compared to lines and
to hyenas there are 11 villages within
the National Park and many more located
just outside it people have lived here
since before the park was opened ludwig
Seaford makes regular visits to schools
in the area his aim is to spark the
children's curiosity and teach them why
Lions are important both for the
environment and also for the people
living here so when you are young you're
a lot more flexible so from that point
of view we expect that the young people
can embrace any new idea especially
scientific facts the other very
important aspect in conservation is it
is a long-term investment one potential
benefit for the locals there's money to
be earned from lion conservation Seifer
regularly takes tourists out into the
wild to experience the Lions at close
range
besides paying a fee to the Ugandan
wildlife Authority tourists also donate
ten US dollars to see firts lion program
the money goes to reimburse farmers
whose livestock have been killed by the
Lions this compensation has changed the
locals attitude towards the Predators we
cannot fully compensate yet a hundred
percent but as the resource flow
increases with more tourists we can also
afford to pay instead of 50 percent 70
percent and the change we see since then
before we would have between five and
twelve lines poison in one year chest
and nowadays within say the last five
six years
we lost knowingly to Lions due to
poisoning at the leopard village center
that he founded villagers earn money
entertaining the visitors at least we
have benefited something from from the
park of course when the visitors are
continue to come we come we are leaving
our members get some money at least
sustainable by supporting the local
communities Ludvik Seifert hopes that
animals and humans will be able to
coexist more peacefully in the future
you